what exactly is reductionism what is the
process of reductionism
that is different
than uh
some of the physicists that you
mentioned that are trying to think
trying to let go of the assumption of
space-time looking beyond isn't that
still trying to come up with a simple
model that explains this whole thing
isn't it still reducing
it's a wonderful question because it
really helps to clarify two different
notions which is scientific explanation
on the one hand
and a particular kind of scientific
explanation on the other which is the
reductionist so the reductionist
explanation is saying i will start with
with
things that are smaller in space-time
and therefore more fundamental where the
laws are more fundamental
so we go
uh to just smaller and smaller scales
whereas with
in science more generally we just say
like when einstein did the special
theory of relativity
he's saying let me have a couple
postulates i will assume that the speed
of light is universal for for all um
[Music]
observers
in uniform motion um and that the laws
of physics so if you for for uniform
motion are are the
that's not a reductionist that those are
saying grant me these assumptions i can
build this entire
concept of space time out of it it's not
a reductionist thing you're not going to
smaller and smaller scales of space
you're you're coming up with these deep
deep principles same thing with this
theory of gravity
right it's the falling elevator idea
right so this is not a reductionist kind
of thing it's it's it's it's it's
something different so simplification
is a bigger thing than just reductionism
that reductionism has been a
particularly useful kind of scientific
explanation for example in
thermodynamics
right where the notion that we have of
heat some macroscopic thing like
temperature and heat
it turns out that neil waltzman and
others
discover well hey you know if we go to
smaller and smaller scales we find these
things called molecules or atoms and if
we think of them as bouncing around
having some kind of energy then um what
we call heat is is a is really can be
reduced to to that
and and so that's a particularly useful
kind of
reduction is a useful kind of scientific
explanation that works within a range of
scales within space-time but we know now
precisely where that has to stop at 10
to the minus 33 centimeters and 10 to
the minus 43 seconds and i would be
impressed if it was 10 to the minus 33
trillion centimeters i'm not terribly
impressed at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters
[Laughter]
i don't even know how to comprehend
either of those numbers frankly uh do
just a small aside because i am
a computer science person i also find
cellular automator beautiful yes and uh
so you have somebody like
uh stephen wolfram who recently has been
very
excitedly exploring um
a proposal for a data structure that
could be
the numbers that would make you a little
bit happier in terms of scale because
they're very very very very tiny
do you like this space of exploration
i'm really thinking letting go of space
time letting go of everything and trying
to think what kind of data structures
could be underneath this whole mess
that's right so if they're thinking
about these as outside of space-time
then that's that's what we have to do
that's what our best theories are
telling us you now have to think outside
of space-time now of course
i should
back up and say
we know that einstein
surpassed newton right but that doesn't
mean that there's not good work to do a
newton there's all sorts of newtonian
physics that takes us to the moon and so
forth and there's lots of good problems
that we want to solve with newtonian
physics the same thing will be true of
space time we'll we'll still it's not
like we're going to stop using space
time we'll continue to do all sorts of
good work there but for for those
scientists who are really looking to
go deeper to actually find the next you
know just like what einstein did to
newton what what are we going to do to
einstein how do we get beyond einstein
and quantum theory to something deeper
then we have to actually let go and and
if we're going to do like this
a automata kind of approach
it's critical that it's not automata in
space time it's automata prior to space
time from which we're going to show how
space time emerges if you're doing
automated within space time well that
might be a fun model but it's not the
radical new step that we need
you